الى ملف التحركات العسكريه في مضيقه
تايوان على ضوء عبور مدمره امريكيه
المضيقه ضمن ما سمته واشنطن نشاطا روتينيا
في السنوات القليله الماضيه عبرت مضيق
تيوان سفن حربيه امريكيه وفي بعض الاحيان
سفن تابعه لدول حليفه مثل بريطانيا او
كندا اثار حفيظه الصين التي تطالب
بالسياده على الجزيره غالبا ما تعزل
الولايات المتحده نشاطها العسكريه قربه
الى ما تقول انه التزامها بابقاء منطقه
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ مفتوحه في
المقابل وعلى واقع العلاقات المتوتره
اساسا بين بيجيل وكيفيه ضاعف الجيش السنين
منذ العام الماضي منوراته العسكريه
البحريه والجويه حول تايوان وجاءت
تدريباته الاخيره غداه اقراري قانوني
تفويض الدفاع الوطني
تايوان تصلوا قيمتها الى 10 مليارات دولار
[موسيقى]
واشنطن سياسه الغموض الاستراتيجي ازاء
ايفي فهي لا تقيموا علاقات دبلوماسيه
رسميه معها لكنها هي اكبر مزود لها
بالاسلحه لتعزيز قدراتها الدفاعيه
لا تخفي الولايات المتحده قلقها ازاءه
زائد الضغوط العسكريه والدبلوماسيه
والاقتصاديه الصينيه على تايوان في
السنوات الاخيره لكن الصين تشكو في
المقابل من تحركات عسكريه ودبلوماسيه
امريكيه على صله بتيوان تقول انها من
شانها الاضرار بالسلام والاستقرار في
المنطقه في ما يويار الماضي اثار الرئيس
الامريكي غضب الصين وذلك حين قال ان بلاده
لن تتوالى عن التدخل عسكريا للدفاع عن
تايوان اذا ما شلت الصين وجوما عسكريا
عليه لكن منسوب التوتر بين واسدجين ارتفع
بشكل غير مسبوق بعد زياره رئيسه مجلس
النواب الامريكي السابق نانسي فيلوسي دي
تايوان في اغسطس بالماضي ينضم الينا الان
من مدينه بس في بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
واستاد العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه فاز بس
والباحث غير في معهد سيجونغ في السيول
اهلا وسهلا بك
مجرد مرور مدمره امريكيه في مضيق تايوان
هل يمكن ان يثير كل هذا الاشكال
نتيجه نتيجه
البعيد سيكون هناك ربما مزيد من التصعيد
وعلى المثل بعيد ايضا الولايات المتحده
ترى في الصين تحديا لهيمانتها وجزء من
مخاوفها لان الصين ماتت اكثر قوه عسكريه
واقتصاديا حتى في المستقبل المنظور يمكنها
ان تتحدى امريكا اقتصاديه
المتحده ترى في خطواتها هذه
الخطوه الاولى للتحدث
الصين اما الصين سترى ما تقوم به من
الخطوات ومن حقها السيادي
الصين انفقت همم مليارات
وعلى اقتصادها لهذا السبب ترى ان محاوله
امريكا لاحتوائها اقتصاديه هو غير عادل
وغير منصف ومحاوله للحد من نموها
الاقتصاديه الرئيس ترامب وعد في مقابله مع
بعض
بانه يعيده حاله النمو في الاقتصاد الصيني
الى حال من الطباطه والتراجع ما نراه الان
هو ممارسه السياسه على طريقه الوصول الى
حافه الهاويه والعوده من دون الوقوع فيها
وكل هذه المناورات العسكريه التي تتم
تراها الصين استفزازه
والسبب انك كده البلدتين اذا ما استطاعاه
المرحله على انهم ليس خائفين من الحرب وان
كلا منهما لا يهمه المجازفه والمخاطره
كقوه كبرى او قوه عظمى عند ذلك لن يضطر اي
بلد منهما للرضوخي لايه شروط سلام من
الطرف الاخر غصبا عن ارادته لهذا السبب كل
بلد يحاول ان يحصل لنفسه على سمعه من لا
يخاف ومن هو المقدام الذي لا يتراجع
واتباع مثل هذا المنطق حقيقه
وراثه المتحده تتبعه افكار الراحل تونس
والذي وضع اسس سياسه الردع الامريكي على
الاقل في مرحله الستينيات والسبعينيات
والتي تحدى فيها
ال ان الميزه هي لصالح من يستطيع تحمل
عنصر
المخاطره لفرض قوته الرابعه المشكله هو ان
كده البلدين يبدو وكان مستعد
لتحمل المخاطر
والمجازفه لتحسين موقعه التفاوض من دون
الاهتمام باحتمالي ان يحدث خطر ما هو خطا
ما يؤدي الى تفاقم الوضع بشكل اكبر ولكن
الملفت سيد كيف ان الولايات المتحده
والصين يؤكدان على الخيار الدبلوماسي
ولكنهما في المقابل
يساعدان نوعا ما التوتر العسكري كيف نفسر
ذلك
اهو قل له علاقه بهذا المنطق الذي كنا
نتحدث عنه من الناحيه العسكريه من المفيد
ان تظهر بوجه من لا يخاف من يجازف من
يحاول الحصول على افضل شروط في صفقه لان
من يظهر وكانه خائف من الحرب هو الذي
سيضطر لتقديم التناسلات في ذات الوقت على
المستوى الطفل لان مثل هذه الطريقه في
المجازفه تحمل في ثناياها مخاطر ايضا لان
اي تعامل استراتيجي من هذا النوع اي يتم
طالب قد تؤدي الى عكس المردود وعكس
المطلوب لو ان ايا من هذا الطرفين الله
يحاول ثار الشروط على الاخر لا يطبقها على
نفس فهذا سيشكل مشكله على مستوى القوه
الناعمه والقوه الدبلوماسيه
المعايير المزدوجه قد ينتهي بها الامر الى
ان تكون مشكله لانك لا تستطيع ان تتنمر
على الاخرين وتكسر احترامهم وتكون لك
شعبيه بين الناس في نفس الوقت
والسبب ان التنمر العسكري واستخدام اللغه
الدبلوماسيه لا تتشابهان ولا تتساوبان لكن
الف من حيث القدره على الدخول في في
الصفقات التنمر هو الذي قد ياتي بالنتائج
هو ليس القوه الناعمه